and as we know all good things must come
to an end we reach our final video given
that his battle versus Wesley so was
round nine from the Aldi box Norway
chess
super tournament the blitz tournament
here Magnus Carlsen took the black
pieces against Wesley so started out
with a slightly unorthodox move order
but immediately transposed into a Dutch
the same opening that he actually played
against Sergey Karjakin now with d5 the
stone ball has been reached but after c4
and Bishop d6 we know this is not going
to be exactly like the game with Sergey
Karjakin because the white knight is on
f3 rather than on h3 c6 has played
Bishop to f4 and the capture has us
continuing down roads travelled often
this is theory if you're wondering why
white can justify not only the knight on
f3 but the double pawns that go with it
that is because the extra control that
it gives white over the centre dark
squares is crucial and very often after
e3 and 9b d7 has been played you're
going to see white develop aggressively
early with the intention to not
necessarily put this king over here
given the G file has been exposed
Wesley played the move Queen to b3 which
immediately puts indirect pressure on
this diagonal including the King on g8
and also causes some dysfunction to
Black's development so Magnus plays b6
the issue is that after 1985 Magnus has
some things to figure out
he needs to guard the e6 pawn but he
also has to be worried about tactics
here where my white might just capture
everything and blow up in the diagonal
rather than allow those tactical
opportunities to continue something like
rook to e8 might even allow things to
blow open Magnus decides to play the
simple move Knight to b8 this move
defends east 6 indirectly with the
bishop but also opens up the Queen so
now black has control and protection
over both of these squares but Wesley
isn't done he castles long and this is
actually a strong move I think white is
better here and white has the
potentially a better attacking chances
Magnus is a little nervous he plays King
to h8 Wesley returns the favor with a
waiting move with the King and after
Queen to e7 we already have our first
moment and the game you're going to see
that Wesley played the move rook to c1
which is a ghoul it's a good full board
balanced approach I think in hindsight
analysis shows that maybe he could have
been more aggressive with a move like h4
the threats are clear he wants to play
things like h5 and h6 and and let's go
for checkmate but just to show a line if
black plays h6 himself not only could
Wesley play moves like bishop of three
and try to bring the Queen around
because this Knight is kind of poisoned
but you can also see variations where
the knight just comes back to f3 and
suddenly the pot on h6 wishes it could
go back in order to guard this g6 square
when you see ideas like 95 about to come
in so again Wesley didn't play that he
played the move rook to c1 and as we
said was taking more of a full board
approach Magnus took his time thinking
allowing us that time for analysis
because he knew we were going to do this
video and then he finally played age six
as you just saw him do
Wesley still could have played a move
like h4 here and tried to call
Magnussen's Bluff but he decides to
immediately retreat the knight which
makes sense again if he can get the
knight in there you may see tactics that
start occurring but after Knight B to d7
we're going to get a trade if that
happens
Wesley traded on d5 Magnus took on d5
and Wesley went into a think before
playing the move 95 as you just saw and
Magnus immediately trading to talk about
I think Wesley just went into I think it
was justified because I don't think 95
was the best move I think Knight to b5
opening up the C file and keeping the
tension in the position given that this
e5 square remains available given that
there's threats like rook into c7 this
is tough for black to show you an
example line I looked at if a six-night
to c7 rook a 7 is played white can even
be as aggressive as a move like rook to
c6 attacking ecigs attacking b6 and
moves like 90 b8 to open up the door
walk into tactics like 95 suddenly
Knight to g6 check is on threat the b6
pawn is hanging you can check the
analysis for yourself but what did
become clear is that after 95 and the
massive simplification here that
happened Wesley so probably regretted
being so directly aggressive as now
black plays Bishop a6 in the game
Wesley tried to trade off things in
order to keep the equality with that
Bishop on a6 being such a dangerous
piece threatening things like Bishop d3
but
despite the trades and the eventual
trade and simplification on the C file
Magnus was was doing well and probably
in hindsight again Wesley would have
thought that maybe in this position
instead of playing the move Knight to e2
where he could have maybe kept this f4
square open he might regret the fact
that he played f4 so quickly allowing
black to trade on c3 as we see Magnus do
again I think 92 was probably White's
last chance to maintain the balance but
he played up for Magnus calculated took
on c3 traded and immediately brought the
Queen to h4 and suddenly you see White's
pawns are weaker than blacks Wesley
plays one believe it or not already
nearly critical blunder with the move
Queen a3 miss placing the queen and
allowing magnets to grab control over
the C file suddenly things are getting
very dangerous
he takes a seven and Magnus takes h2 and
Wesley realizes Queen to c2 check
followed by Queen c1 made as an issue a3
seems to do the job of protecting this
idea but after the very very strong
Queen to g2 that we just saw Magnus play
you see rook d1 is not possible because
of Queen c2 what the c1 is not possible
because of the trade which means the
only move is rook e1 and now Magnus just
continues to play the two-step plays
Queen up to a tempo still rook d1 not
possible because of Queen check rook c1
not possible because of trades and takes
here with check and that means if we
have to run to h1 well then black just
gained two temples along the way to
gobbling up not just the e3 pawn but
eventually the d4 pawn as you see
magnets grab now so suddenly it becomes
clear that Zoe's position is far from
desirable Queen to d7 makes sense it's a
fork but Magnus can protect both of them
with a check and tempo the King goes to
a-1 and Magnus has sort of a pleasant
choice here he probably could have even
brought the Queen back to c6 and been
much better in the ensuing rook ending
but calculates the d4 opening the Queen
to guard the pawn while she still guards
the rook was good enough and that's
because rook to g1 threatening checkmate
can be met by rook to g8 and rook to d1
can be met as we're about to see the
players play sorry I got a little bit
ahead of that in the analysis rook to d1
can be met by the move d3 sacrificing
the d3 pawn for the f5
upon which proves to be a more critical
pawn as it provides protection for a
five
Wesley takes it Magnus gobbles up f4 and
you start to see that white may be
headed toward a position where black
actually has four passed pawns on the
Kings side as soon as he can eliminate
e5 Queen 86 has played we get a check we
get another check and now the f4 pawn is
going to join the attack as the players
I believe that's Maxine Busta the crowd
looking over maybe even Aronian began to
gather around and watch Magnus do his
thing as he was nearing his way toward a
victory at the Norway blitz super
tournament rook to c3 the Queen goes to
d5 as we're about to see offering the
Queen trade and still putting the
question - so how he intends to deal
with so many passed pawns over here on
the Kings side
Wesley realized that his best chance is
to go for counter play so he gobbles up
the b61 after Queen takes e5 though his
best efforts to try to stay in the game
of the race that begin with the move
pawn a4 run into serious issues as soon
as black points out that his pawns are
faster rook to f8 the rook goes behind
the pawn and we know what's coming next
we have threats here and Queen to b4
King to g8 rook to f3 Magnus is going to
play Queen to f5 which is a nice move
because not only does it keep the the
battery the protection of the f4 pawn
but it opens up the new pawn to get into
the storm Wesley is running out of ideas
Queen to c4 pins the pawn but after a
simple move King age 7
so realizes that four pawns versus two
pawns is slightly favorable for black
and the inability to stop threats like a
five and a four are probably enough to
throw in the towel Wesley takes a little
bit of time here before agreeing to this
result and offering Magnus exactly what
he got there which of course was a clear
first victory at the ulti button or wage
has super term at the blitz tournament
Magnus did get first and as we see the
final standing show - Cara Nakamura
they're a full two points behind
magnus carlsen tied with Levon Aronian
for second and third place showing you
the world champions dominance in blitz
in his home on his home turf exciting
stuff we hope you enjoyed this series we
appreciate you following it from start
to finish please subscribe to our
YouTube channel here congratulations to
Magnus for a dominant performance and
thanks to Peter doctors and the chess
comm team on site for bringing us these
videos and opportunity to bring you the
analysis that we did here